OK, guys, let's go back to high school.
Does anyone remember that feeling
of walking into the school cafeteria
with your tray in your hand
and not knowing where to sit?
Yeah, I see some people nodding, OK, cool.
You might have sat alone,
or perhaps more likely,
you looked for someone who felt familiar.
You sat with a group of people
that reminded you of you.
And even today,
when deciding where to sit,
how many of you
chose to sit next to someone
who looked or felt different from you?
I would bet that not many of you did that.
I guess not much changes
in some situations,
whether you're 17 or you're 70.
We've all likely felt this tendency
to gravitate towards people who look,
think and act like us.
It's comfortable,
but it can also be harmful
because this polarization
that we face today
isn't just about believing
that the other side is factually wrong.
We are beginning to see the other side
as malevolent beings
with a hateful and hidden agenda.
And you can see this.
You can see this in the screaming
cable news pundits,
the politicians who vote down bills
just because they come
from the other side of the aisle.
The hate groups
that violently attack people
who are different from themselves.
When I see these things as a teenager,
I just feel so sad, so angry
and so scared of this world
that I'm soon going
to be entering as an adult.
But there's something that I found
in having conversations with my peers
that I think can be a path forward
from all of this.
An approach that focuses on conversations
with the intent to listen and learn.
Not to win and not to agree.
So I'm a 17-year-old
from Naperville, Illinois.
In the summer before my sophomore
year of high school,
I attended the ACLU National Advocacy
Institute's high school program
in Washington, DC.
During this program,
I had the chance to take part in a lot
of different political discussions.
And I remember this one conversation
about the death penalty in particular.
So back then,
I wholeheartedly believed
in this meaning of an eye for an eye.
That punishment should be equal
to the offense because, you know,
that's what I grew up hearing.
And so I argued the same.
I was, however, met
with immediate opposition.
My peers told me that the death penalty
is state sanctioned murder
and that it reinforces the very behavior
that it's trying to suppress.
I tried arguing that the death
penalty deters crime,
but then my peers told me that in states
without the death penalty,
the murder rate is actually
significantly lower.
I then tried arguing that the death
penalty brings closure
for the victim's families,
only to be told that the length
between sentencing and execution
actually puts the victim's families
through an agonizing wait period.
So by this point, I realized
that this debate --
Not going all that great for me.
I realized that my
perspective was inherited,
and this is when I decided
to stop trying to win the debate,
and instead I just listened.
And in the months that followed,
I took it upon myself to learn more.
I pored over articles and data
from sources ranging
from the more liberal,
like the Brennan Center for Justice,
to the more conservative,
like The Heritage Foundation.
And I learned that historically,
capital punishment has been
disproportionately applied
to people of color.
And that the death penalty
isn’t actually proven to deter crime.
Slowly, my thinking changed.
And this change only happened
because I engaged with people
who had opposing perspectives.
You know, it's hard to break out
of your own echo chamber
because most of the time we don't realize
that we're even in one
until we're out of it.
But this was my first step.
So shortly after this experience,
I started a nonpartisan initiative
called Project TEAL
to encourage and empower
high school students
to become politically involved.
We discuss a lot of different issues
like education equity,
voter suppression, racial justice.
And I've seen some amazing things happen
when people just talk to one another.
Understanding and accepting
of our differences.
I actually remember this one conversation
in the summer of 2020.
There was a boy and a girl
who were debating
the merit of the Black Lives
Matter movement.
And I remember being afraid
that their conversation
would evolve into an argument.
But it didn't.
Instead, I learned
that the girl, who is Black,
came from a family
that had been through a couple
of rough instances with the police.
And the boy, who was the son of a cop,
came from an upbringing
in which BLM was labeled
as a movement in defiance of the police.
Later on, I was surprised to learn
that, though they still didn't agree,
the boy and the girl learned something
about the other
that they didn't know before.
And more than that, they appreciated
how it shaped the other person's
unique perspective.
And this was only possible
because they didn't delve
into a shouting match
or call each other disrespectful names.
And for me, this was an “aha!” moment.
I realized that we shouldn't back away
from discussing polarizing issues,
even if it's with people
who disagree with us.
Sure, it's uncomfortable,
and yeah, I'd probably agree
that we don't change our minds
most of the time.
But we can better understand
opposing perspectives,
which can help us to better advocate
for our own beliefs.
And maybe, just maybe,
it even allows us to reach a compromise
when the situation demands it.
So I think the question remains.
How can we create space
for this kind of bipartisan discourse?
Well, I think the first step
is finding a community.
When I think back
to my experience in the ACLU,
I think the reason we were able
to have that civil discourse
was because we recognized
that we were a part of a greater cause.
And it's because my peers knew me,
not just as an opposing voice,
but as Shreya,
their peer, their fellow
teen activist and their friend.
And when we are able
to recognize what unites us,
it becomes so much easier
to have conversations
about what divides us.
And most Americans actually validate
what I have seen in practice.
While 77 percent of American voters
polled before the 2020
presidential election
said that they had just a few
or no close friends
who supported the other side's candidate,
79 percent of Americans agree
that creating opportunities
for bipartisan civil discourse
would be effective in reducing divisions.
Seventy-nine percent.
That's pretty incredible, if you ask me.
We all have affinity groups
that we can join.
Maybe it's a friend group
at your place of work,
a book club at the local library
or the PTA at your kid's school.
Whatever this group is,
try to have an uncomfortable conversation
with them at least once a week.
Now, OK, what exactly constitutes
as uncomfortable?
I would say that's really
up for you to decide.
It can be about politics, sure.
Or it can be about a different
topic entirely,
like religion or identity.
Whatever this topic may be,
just talk about something
that’s uncomfortable, unconventional
and meaningful to you.
And most importantly,
do it with the intent to listen and learn,
not to win and not to agree.
And you know, another tip.
Make sure to stay off of your phone
for this conversation.
Yeah.
You know, as someone
who's pretty much obsessed with TikTok,
I completely understand how addicting
social media can be.
Believe me.
But by discussing polarizing
issues online,
we lose that person-to-person connection
that really humanizes
opposing perspectives,
that allows us to see
and empathize with one another.
Because by having these conversations,
you will gain insight into people
who think differently than you do.
And who knows, maybe
you'll convince someone
of a belief that you hold dearly,
or maybe you'll even be moved
to reconsider your own viewpoint.
In a month's time, I'm going to be
graduating from high school.
(Applause)
Over the past four years,
I’ve learned a lot about creating
positive discourse,
but I’m still scared of this polarization,
this growing unwillingness to view
those who politically disagree with us
as human.
Honestly, it's a little overwhelming
to think that I'm soon
going to enter this reality
where I'll be confronted
with this division.
Where I’ll be stereotyped and judged
by my ideology, my identity
and my way of thinking by people
who don't even know the real me.
As a teenager, it's a lot.
And I know that many of my fellow
Gen Zers feel the exact same way.
And this is precisely why addressing
this polarization crisis is so urgent
and demands action from all of us.
Just for one moment,
go back to that high school cafeteria,
But this time you sit down
with that other crowd.
The kids who didn't look
or think like you do.
And just imagine
what you could have learned.
Thank you.
(Applause)